I was in the Navy for 26 years, and I was
a hospital corpsman. Here's a great opportunity
for veterans. I know you raised your right
hand and you swore to defend the Constitution
against all enemies, foreign and domestic.
Would you like to know what that really meant?
Would you like to know those source documents
to federalist papers and read those and understand
what it means to be an American and defend
our Constitution, and get an education that
will propel you forward. Your GI bill is very
valuable and there are a lot of people out
there who would love to take it, but you're
coming to an institution that won't take it.
In fact, we're going to supplement your GI
bill with money from Americans who believe
in liberty, in the Constitution, and they
want you to have this awesome education.
Why would you not want that? When you leave
the military, you go to the transition assistance
office, and they let you know, they try to
bring you back into the civilian world. We
know how those civilians can be. Here the
transition is also something that you have
to go through. And so, we have provided opportunity
for you to transition. We have a dorm that
we have been housing some of our veterans.
We call it Fort Awesome, and it's awesome.
We hook you up with an advisor that was prior
military. You come and talk to me and I was
in the Navy. I understand about transition,
and so we work with you to make that smooth.
This is a great opportunity. So jump on it.